en cette année nous avons comme tous les
ans une dizaine de pays présents à
montoir l'amérique du sud est
représentée par l'équateur par exemple
et puis nous avons aussi le ballet
national du salvador pays qui sont à
présent pour la première fois en 43 ans
de festival
nous avons également la guadeloupe
présente pour la première fois au
festival nous aurons un témoignage
culturel important kalimantan la partie
indonésienne de bornéo
nous avons aussi des grands ballets on
peut parler du ballet russe 6 vers qu un
des plus grands ensembles de russie qui
nous fait l'honneur de venir cette année
avant toi vous avez également le tibet
et nous avons aussi de tibet le tibet
qui est un pays rarement représentés
dans les festivals qui est venu pour la
dernière fois à montoir en 1987
c'est difficile d'avoir ce type de pics
de pays d'enhaut aux manifestations et
on est bien heureux d'accueillir le
tibétain institut de cette année